seit monaten beschäftigt mich die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
stammzuschauer werden das wissen sie
spricht für mich ging jede ethik und
jede moral die mich mein elternhaus
lehrte er ist heute lasse ich die uni
klinik bonn meldet jetzt noch 800
mitarbeiter ans gesundheitsamt der grund
seit mehr als zwei wochen geht jetzt
diese impfpflicht im gesundheitswesen in
bayern bekommen menschen die sich gegen
die krone impfung entschieden haben nun
auch post vom gesundheitsamt sich
beraten zu lassen ich finde die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht falsch
und während morgen im bundestag über
eine mögliche impfpflicht entschieden
wird ist mit also die das finale seine
impfpflicht debatte über die 18 wurde ja
schon entschieden die kommen nicht finde
ich dass wir an diesem abend vor dem
morgigen die partie nicht vergessen
sollten dass wir schon längst eine
impfpflicht haben und das ist die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht also
da bin ich tatsächlich völlig andere
meinung als du weißt ich bin von der
allgemeinen impfpflicht tatsächlich kein
fan aber wenn es irgendwo eine
impfpflicht gibt die man sinnvollerweise
haben sollten unser mann dann in
bestimmten einrichtungen gerade in
krankenhäusern warum weil zum beispiel
krankenpfleger krankenschwestern weil
die ihre sozusagen ihre ihre
schutzbefohlenen haben das sind die
menschen die sich dort notgedrungene
weise aufhalten das gleiche geht in dem
pflegeheim deswegen wenn irgendwo im
pflicht dann dort und du bist jetzt hier
sehr große worte gleich zu anfang ich
glaube das ist durchaus rational
vertretbar und begründbar dort in
solchen einrichtungen pflichten zu haben
also krankenschwestern physiotherapeutin
ist klingt ja auch für medizin studenten
für studenten der zahnmedizin das sind
ja alles bereiche die in die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht fallen
ich halte das auch aus einem anderen
grund noch für falsch du hast gerade die
krankenhäuser auch angesprochen ms hat
letztens auch ich glaube ich hab's im
fokus gelesen der hat eine
krankenschwester und auch dafür plädiert
ich meine es bei der focus das heißt die
pfleger auch arbeiten kommen dürfen die
nicht geimpft sind wir haben in der
pflege schon wenig personal die menschen
haben sich zwei jahre für dieses land
aufgeopfert auch viele und ich finde ich
denke immer darüber nach was ist wenn
die gesellschaft mal etwas von mir
fordert wer sich nicht bereit bin zu
geben was ist dann und mein
hauptargument aber dann eröffnen wir
auch mal die runde sonst wird sie im
monolog mein hauptargument gegen die
einrichtungs beziehungen pflicht ist
dass man sich ja auch ansteckend kann
also wenn es und da glaube sogar ich
wäre ich vielleicht sogar für die
allgemeine impfpflicht gewesen wenn man
sich nicht dann mehr anstecken kann und
ist sozusagen zu einer ausrottung führen
würde von corona dann wäre ich auch für
die einrichtungs bezogen pflicht das ist
aber nicht der fall aber wie sehen sie
das herr steininger also gebt gebt ihnen
absolut recht wir haben uns ja auch als
union sehr schwer getan als wir im
dezember der einrichtungs bezogen
impfpflicht zugestimmt haben damals ja
aber noch in der in der diskussion dass
es eventuell eine allgemeine impfpflicht
gibt und man dann in diesem wichtigen
bereich voran geht und gleichzeitig
sehen wir jetzt eigentlich ist es
derzeit einen papiertiger die landkreise
sollen das ganze überprüfen sind dazu
auch gar nicht in der lage ich
persönlich kenne keinen einzigen
bußgeldbescheid der erstellt worden ist
wir haben keine betretungsverbote und am
schluss eine regelung die nicht
kontrolliert wird und die nichts bringt
da muss man schon darüber sprechen ob
man die nicht an aussetzt insbesondere
wenn wir morgen dafür sorgen dass es
keine impfpflicht geben wird ja aber es
ist ja wirklich spannend wenn man sich
ansieht wie sich jetzt die politik
sondern von dem verabschiedet was ich
selber mit beschlossen hat das ist das
sehr spannend auch als opposition dass
wir jetzt nicht mehr daran erinnern
können was sie eigentlich mit
beschlossen haben und man muss ja fragen
wie gehen wir mit dieser impfpflicht um
ja jahrelang haben wir gehört dass sind
die helden der krise ein pfleger dies
stehen an der vordersten front und jetzt
gibt es den europaweit berufsverbote für
menschen die wir vorher noch als helden
gefeiert haben mit keiner einzigen
begründung mehr wenn man sich durch
schließlich begründung des deutschen
gesundheitsministeriums warum es denn
diese nicht geben muss dann steht da
drinnen weil corona eine höchst
gefährliche tödliche infektionskrankheit
ist so jetzt ist aber omikron
ungefährlicher wie die grippe also nach
dieser logik bräuchten wir eine
impfpflicht für die krippe die grippe
gefährlicher die omikron sagen alle
zahlen bloß es ist natürlich
es gibt keinen unterschied bei der
ansteckung zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften also sie können ungeimpft
oder geimpft im altersheim genau so
jemanden anstecken wie sonst also es
gibt auch keine logische denken es ist
einfach nur eine politik die
mittlerweile nicht mehr nach vorne und
nach hinten weiß und nicht ein sich
eingestehen kann ich habe mich geirrt
hier würde ich gerne frau bär reinholen
kann man das so sagen ungefährlicher als
die grippe also ich finde solche
aussagen immer sehr gefährlich weil es
natürlich sehr unterschiedlich ist wie
es bei den menschen ankommt es gibt eben
diejenigen und ich wirklich schon alles
gesehen die tatsächlich nichts hatten
jetzt auch beim micro aber auch welche
die wirklich sehr sehr stark gelitten
haben viel viel stärker als man das bei
einer grippe machen würde und was
natürlich nicht stimmt was sie gerade
behauptet haben dass man sich an dinge
nicht mehr erinnert die man im letzten
jahr abgestimmt hat das hat ja schon
steininger ja auch gesagt es war eine
andere ausgangssituation
die ampel hat er auch ich sage jetzt
noch oscar
haben
ist die vorstufe dann auch zu einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht und die
vorbereitungen wurden ja teilweise auch
noch bei delta getroffen das heißt man
muss natürlich sagen dass omikron jetzt
eine andere variante ist die weniger
gefährlich ist ja aber die natürlich
trotzdem warum jetzt nicht so entwickelt
hat dass wir eben sagen auch als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion wir brauchen jetzt
keine allgemeine impfpflicht weil es
eben nicht in der verhältnismäßigkeit
steht und jetzt macht die ampel tricks
an dieser stelle schon alleine mücken
abstimmungsmodus jetzt versuchen sie
halt tatsächlich noch was durchzudrücken
ich habe auch ich habe in bayern abitur
gemacht hat man nicht gelernt dass 18
plus 50 60 ist aber so scheint es
anscheinend jetzt auch bei der ampel zur
zeit ist es ein totales chaos die
regierung hat überhaupt keinen
gemeinsamen entwurf vorgelegt also die
einzigen die wirklich stringent einen
entwurf der auch ein impf register
vorsieht vorliegt dessen wir und ohne im
krieg ist da braucht man sowas überhaupt
nicht anzufangen bestimmt da muss ich
mich ihnen anschließen die cdu/csu haben
wir ihre position natürlich gewechselt
ist vernünftig wo man eher kritisieren
muss ist ja der mehrheits
steigbügelhalter der regierung das ist
die fdp die an mittlerweile einfach die
bordsteinschwalbe von rot grün ist als
inhaltlich kommen von beiden vielleicht
nicht aber inhaltlich würde ich das holz
stein schweine von rot-grün sebastian
als politikredakteur von bett gehst du
damit auch das ist mir das ist mir eins
drüber würde ich sagen die ampel hat
schon irgendwie auch ein bisschen
zusammengefunden jetzt dass das das
schrank für das ist mir schon der fall
sein
naja gut dass manche unstimmigkeiten in
der möglicherweise dass das kann schon
sagen nein aber ich glaube das
interessante bei dieser diskussion ist
er kenne durchaus diese gegenargumenten
die jetzt gerade ins ins feld geführt wo
er dran trotzdem dafür für die
einrichtungs bezogen ich würde sagen
alles was was hilft gegen krohne ist
immer erst mal gut und gerade wenn
menschen dort hat sich mein vater lebt
auch im pflegeheim zum beispiel wo ich
dann am anfang fragte wieso ist denn
jetzt schon wieder zu bei ihnen hieß es
ja wir haben hier corona fälle und so
weiter nämlich mehr menschen sind doch
jetzt aber eine durchgehende sind ja gar
nicht alle geben ist dass ich mich wieso
sind ja nicht alle gm sprechen ja manche
alten wollen das nicht okay muss man
akzeptieren akzeptiere ich aber dann
auch selbst pfleger teilweise und da
muss ich sagen da habe ich dann schon
irgendwie sehr seltsames gefühl aber da
finde ich wenn das dazu hilft
möglicherweise zum beispiel wie russland
zu reduzieren sondern sich auch impfen
im dienste der menschen für die diese
menschen dort ja eigentlich tätig sind
und muss natürlich auch sagen also wir
erwarten natürlich also ich erwarte von
jeder pflegerinnen von jedem pfleger
dass er oder sie sich impfen lässt weil
wenn man im gesundheitsbereich arbeitet
dann auch mit höchst wunderwaffen
gruppen dann erwarte ich das schon
gleichzeitig ist natürlich eine pflicht
einzuführen sehr großer eingriff auch
ins grundrecht und wir haben das ganze
im dezember beschlossen da gibt es auch
noch ein anderes gesetz mit den anderen
maßnahmen wurde das landratsamt geworden
ist aber damals haben wir tatsächlich
bei delta gesprochen und das war noch
mal eine ganz andere nummer jetzt unter
omikron sehen wir dass an der stelle
nicht und deswegen muss man aus meiner
sicht auch darüber sprechen ob man die
jetzt nicht aussetzt aber wir mussten
sie müssen sich aber wirklich auch
aufpassen bei stellen sie sich vor ich
weiß nur von österreich in österreich in
ungefähr 20 prozent des pflegepersonals
nicht geimpft bei den ärzten zehn
prozent ja jetzt verzichten wir jetzt
bei unbekannt wo sehr viele menschen
noch infiziert sind wo viele im
krankenstand sind aufgrund dieser
absolut dämlichen quarantäne verzichten
wir würden wir verzichten auf 20 prozent
des pflegepersonals und jammern dass wir
viel zu wenig personal haben anstatt
dass wir das personal ausbauen in den
jahren der korona epidemie die
pflegebetten erweitern dass wir das
gesundheitssystem
anpassen die jeder vernünftige
unternehmer das machen würde ja man geht
auch darüber dass wir viel zu wenig
pflegepersonal haben wir müssen halt die
leute gescheit zahlen wir müssen die
leute ausbilden und das dauert jahre und
jahre lang ist nichts getan worden und
jetzt sagen wir der verzicht einfach so
oder so wie offenbar tausend menschen
die leben retten stellen sie sich vor
sie liegen im alltag und es kommt
niemand und und sagen der pflege steht
vor der tür und sagt ich würde ihnen
gerne helfen aber ich bin umgekehrt wir
können ja auch noch mal weitergehen das
thema krankenhaus und pflegeheim sind ja
auch immer die sehr emotionalen punkte
mit denen man sich beschäftigt aber zu
der einrichtungs bezogen pflicht warum
ist mich auch so sehr stört mich stolz
aber auch bei pfleger nicht und auch da
dagegen auch eine krankenschwester ich
bin dafür ist jeder frei wer seinen
körper entscheidet auch mit blick auf
die wohnanlage aber was ich eigentlich
sagen will ist wenn zum beispiel mein
physiotherapeut der hat jetzt aufgehört
der kann mich jetzt auch nicht mehr
behandeln weil er hat sich gegen die
impfung entschieden hat dann so ein
schreiben geschickt jetzt auf mit seiner
praxis und so weiter und da hab ich mir
dann die frage gestellt die würde ich
auch gerne an frau bär geben weil ich
mich die auch so oft in der politik
gefragt habe mein physiotherapeut und
ich sind ja eigentlich zwei erwachsene
menschen und wenn ich entscheide ich
finde das völlig in ordnung ich arbeite
ja auch mit menschen die sich nicht
gegen die grippe beispielsweise impfen
gelassen haben warum darf dann
eigentlich eher nicht mehr mit mir
trainieren wie konnte das denn
eigentlich passieren dass die politik
auf solche entscheidung für mich trifft
und damit auf den physiotherapeuten ja
gut er arbeitet natürlich nicht nur mit
ihnen sondern der arbeitet natürlich mit
vielen anderen patienten und mein physio
therapeuten zum beispiel der ist total
dagegen also der ist geht das ganze team
ist geimpft und der sagt auch er wird
nie auch wenn die masten mal abgeschafft
sind wird er sie trotzdem nicht ablegen
er und sein ganzes team bleiben auch bei
ft zwei masken weil er zum beispiel sehr
viele krebspatienten hat und weil er
einfach möchte dass gerade diese wunder
rebellengruppen die auch zu ihm kommen
und die kommen dann in den raum wo sie
und er vorher alleine waren natürlich
wird desinfiziert aber erst sagt der
eine ganz große fürsorgepflicht weil die
krebspatienten in zum beispiel angerufen
haben und gesagt haben wenn er nicht die
höchsten schutzmaßnahmen trifft dann
kommen die nicht mehr und ich glaube es
geht nicht immer nur um einen selber
sondern das geht eben auch um viele
andere die man da zu schützen hat die
frage ist natürlich klar bei den berufen
wo fängt man an wo hört man auf wo sind
ganz besonders wohl nabu-gruppen kann
man auch über ich habe heute in der
zuschrift bekommen von der
krankenschwester aus meinem wahlkreis
die angesagt bevor der bundes für uns
ein führt soll das mal für alle
staatsbeamte einführen das war ihr
vorschlag das erst mal der staat mit
gutem beispiel voran jahre alt ist war
es eigentlich auch keine schlechte idee
also ich glaube man muss halt immer
demokratie dann auch mal diskutieren wir
haben im letzten jahr
und dem vorletzten ja schon seit zwei
jahren das sehr viel tun müssen was man
vorher so nicht kannte man hat ja auch
keine blaupause so eine pandemie gab es
eben vorher noch nicht wo man sich drauf
zurückziehen konnte da wurden sicherlich
auch nicht alles richtig gemacht in den
letzten zwei jahren aber ich kann schon
sagen auf jeden fall für die große
mehrheit unserer kolleginnen und
kollegen dass man wirklich immer auch in
der aktuellen lage anpassung der es nach
bestem wissen und gewissen gemacht hat
nur momentan sehe ich das nicht weil ich
schon sehen und da bin ich anderer
meinung als sie das ich schon glaube
dass aus vielen parteitaktischen und
parteipolitischen spielchen jetzt in der
aktuellen ampel weil man eben nicht
zusammen gerauft ist weil es nämlich
wirklich kraft ohne ende an jeder stelle
an jeder ecke weil sie überhaupt nicht
zusammenpassen weil es nur ums reine
regieren geht dass wir morgen großes
abstimmungs chaos und große fehler
erleben werden und da wenn man wirklich
offenen auges rein